German reunification is often seen as
one of the definitive events that marked
the end of the Cold War yet something
seldom discussed with respect to German
unification is how many people across
the world not only opposed to reunified
Germany but did so fiercely now the
biggest long-term opponent to German
reunification was the USSR since the
last time Germany had been whole Great
Patriotic War every leader of the USSR
had strongly opposed any notion of a
united Germany by the 1980s there being
two Germany's was a simple fact of life
so a quick overview Germany since the
end of the Second World War had lost
territory and been split into two states
the capitalist Democratic Federal
Republic of Germany also known as West
Germany and the German Democratic
Republic known as East Germany which was
a communist Soviet puppet state in the
mid-1980s Mikhail Gorbachev became the
general secretary of the USSR and due to
internal economic and social problems
his attention was turned elsewhere he
introduced reforms across the USSR and
took a much more hands-off approach to
its puppet states in the Eastern Bloc in
1989 the communist regimes in Eastern
Europe started to collapse as East
Germany's rulers began to lose their
grip on power the notion of German
reunification was put forward by West
German Chancellor Helmut Kohl Gorbachev
was busy trying to keep the Soviet Union
together and so reluctantly acquiesced
to German reunification however it
should be noted that Gorbachev was under
the impression that a united Germany
would leave NATO and become a neutral
nation so with the USSR's blessing the
primary obstacle to reunification was
out of the way right well no in the West
support for German reunification wasn't
exactly common the exception to this was
the USA which under President George HW
Bush was extremely supportive of the
United Germany
whereas in Western Europe many were
suspicious and quite concerned about
German reunification West Germany was
already the largest economy in Western
Europe and if it were to incorporate the
East Germany's lead would increase
massively for France led by President
Francois Mitterrand German reunification
could potentially derail his and Cole's
efforts to bring about much greater
levels of European integration as such
the price for France's blessing would be
Germany signing up to a brand-new
European currency instead of continuing
with the use of the strong Jewish mark
Italy's Prime Minister Giulio Andreotti
summed up many people's views quite well
when he said I love Germany so much I
prefer to see two of them so in the West
by far the biggest opponent to German
reunification was Britain led by
Margaret Thatcher Thatcher feared that a
reunified Germany would economically
dominate the Khans
she was also worried that Germany would
seek to forcibly retake the territories
it had lost after the Second World War
thus she petitioned Gorbachev to
increase the number of Soviet soldiers
in East Germany in order to better
resist its reunification in the end
though events overtook the politicians
and Germany was by popular demand
reunited on July the 1st 1990 it was
agreed that the current German Polish
border would be permanent and that
Germany would remain a member of NATO in
that East Germany would never host
nuclear weapons and that was that just
remembered that this reunification
wasn't without its opponents I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patrons
that you see on screen now and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette David
archaeologist
Zarqa flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Yashar Enderman Chris wicker Myles
Bailey Brent guard Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swann tun Rick Onion duck Maggie
pax Kowski Winston k-word phacelia vadas
Anthony Beckett Adam Harvey Ike Skye
Chappell and the amusement park Ives